akkus atlas einer der größten
nachtfalter der welt fügung giganteum
was aussieht wie blätter sind gespenst
schrecken dynastisch hercules zusammen
mit dem riesen bock käfer der größte
seiner art
eine kleine auswahl aus adrian kovacevic
sammlung der züchter inszeniert seine
insekten und spinnen in internetvideos
und begeistert damit millionen zuschauer
berührungsängste fehlanzeige ich hatte
schon immer insekten zu hause gehabt
habe immer insekten gehalten insekten
gerne gefangen von draußen immer
gezüchtet das gehört dazu das gehört zu
mir dass ich insekten habe und halte und
das ist etwas normales weit mehr als
eine halbe million menschen folgen ihm
allein auf facebook
neben seinem insekten handel verdient er
mit der lizenzierung der viralen videos
geld zwischen 200 und 400 euro erhält er
pro clip
dazu kommt oft noch eine
gewinnbeteiligung je skurriler der
content desto höher die chance seine
videos an agenturen zu verkaufen
die bestseller sind seines elfi videos
selbst fühlt sich normalerweise nicht
schlimmer
außer ist unterstützt große gespenster
strecken die ziemlich große krallen
haben sich inzwischen aber neben den
augen halten dass das eher unangenehm so
was auch sehr unangenehm war fast schon
die größte schnecke bewältigt hatte ja
die war er politisch dreh platz für die
videos ist eine einfamilienhaussiedlung
in der nähe von karlsruhe in den keller
seiner eltern herrschen 24 grad celsius
so mögen es die tiere am liebsten wie
diese goliath käfer die bis zu elf
zentimeter lang werden und in afrika
heimisch sind
ein anderes highlight seiner
australischen riesenschaden 250 euro ist
ein paar bei sammlern wert rund 50
insekten und spinnen arten besitzt
adrian kolakovic die meisten von ihnen
sind gottesanbeterinnen es gibt arten
wie diese die sich perfekt den blättern
anpassen zwischen den mädchen total
blätter
es gibt auch natürlich arten die lebende
blätter imitieren 100 die blüten die mit
ihren es gibt wirklich eine riesige
vielfalt an arten dass das sehr
spannenden faszinierenden und
gottesanbeterin adrian kosak ihr wird es
insekten sind pflegeleicht während seine
fleisch fressen und gottesanbeterinnen
leben der tiere wie heuschrecken oder
spinnen essen bekommen die
stabheuschrecken aus madagaskar alle
drei tage
frische brombeer blätter serviert
insekten sind die größte tier klasse
überhaupt in den tropischen regenwäldern
leben noch viele unentdeckte arten drei
bis viermal jährlich geht der gebürtige
pole auf entdeckungstour nach
südostasien um neue tiere mitzubringen
natürlich nur solche die nicht unter
artenschutz stehen
exotische insekten als ware und
haustiere regelmäßig beschweren sich
tierschützer bei ihm viele leute für
menschen auch das zu sehr die insekten
gerne kein bewusstsein arbeitet als
einzige was die empfindest temperaturen
und feuchtigkeit die nährstoffe in den
futtertiere was die festung zum beispiel
und das muss man einfach anbieten und
dann ist alles gut
der erfolg in den sozialen medien zieht
längst nicht nur insekten fans an 2017
lud in die italienische marke gucci samt
insekten zu einem exklusiven mode event
nach florenz 1
besonders gut kommen diese dorn gespenst
strecken bei seinen fans an wegen des
hohen skurrilität und ekel faktor
mit jedem video steigt auch die
popularität von insekten als haustier
ich bekomme schon immer mehr anfangen
möchte ich schon auch jedes jahr dass es
immer mehr leute interessiert sind
insekten zu halten anstatt vielleicht zu
reptilien zu halten
in sektor eberl aus der allgemeinen ist
er was neues ist ein neues markt
insekten für die einen plagegeister
beängstigend und eklig für adrian
kolakovic die spannendsten und schönsten
tiere der welt